so that just happened you go first
um well first of all I should clarify
for before you type in the comments let
me tell you what this is um I think we
got it no when I saw the episode where
you find out that wife actually saw the
first Steven universe episode I ever saw
the word ground is in future and
everything um
they were advertising this episode so I
figured out okay this is a crossover
with some show called Uncle grandpa
uh hey Barry kind of wisely in the first
couple second point out it's not canon
um I'm going to make the assumption
having never seen the show that uncle
grandpa is surreal base strange humor um
kind of like a creepy male relative
version of Mary Poppins you probably
don't want hanging out in your bedroom
yes um and it's basically nothing but
surreal weird jokes that has a hint of
an arc with Stephen trying to figure out
how to use a shield in stage there was
story oh but it's mostly excuse to do
just kooky silly surreal humor um I have
never seen the show
oh my dear having actually after
watching this episode I don't really
want to I here's the thing the second
this is kind of Olaf effect for me the
second that guy showed up I was ready to
hate him I am just like and set mine to
despise you know just I am giving you no
chances I was immediately prejudiced to
it um and at some point I was very glad
I made that choice but other times I
will admit I did legitimately laugh and
the tiger was the best care the Tiger
the tiger also had no lines if I'm from
roar the tiger the up him say
that it isn't can I thought was very
funny the him saying that he was there
in the ship was to the best jothee ad in
the world I was very I was the best joke
at the the ad popping up pearls reaction
to their head separating and going
around the earth I thought was very much
just her cracking if you like I just I
mean this they were funny moments but I
mean I feel like it was like five really
funny moments but nothing of any
redeeming value or quality in between
them like cuz there are other episodes
where I'm just like oh well there were
only two funny moments but at least
there was like story or something well
and I think is he spells out April Fool
so I'm gonna guess I guess a fool's
episode but like the same bat-time and
whatever I would rather they just ran 15
minutes of the room um wouldn't much
rather watch unedited oh I just have
just hit the crystal gems wandering
around in the background the reacting
tatami was so that'd be amazing
oh if you're gonna do a cross room like
I I kill for a cross over something like
the amazing world of gumball or
something like a show I like but well
I'm a little thing at the end where he's
checking off all the crossovers which I
mean I'm assuming he's done crossover
all nights like is Ed Edd and Eddy even
still ah like I don't even I don't think
it is but maybe that's the joke like
he's going to appear on all of them or
whatever surprise crossover with
Children's Hospital at adults with that
would have been great
Steven ends up inaudible but like Danna
would have loved your venture with
crossover Venture Brothers or freaking
boondocks I want to see LSD steam the
universe i adventuretime that'd be
interesting that would be amazing
yeah but I how I put I have a strange
even though it doesn't always work I
have a strange respect for people that
try really surreal silly humor because
it is such a risk and you're putting so
much out there and you run such the big
threat of being so incredibly annoying
and just failing bigger than like
anything else in comedy outside of maybe
shot
humor um you just run this big even kind
of more than shocked you modalities guys
ok we're doing no no no there's a iris
that you run so he Cartoon Network we're
talking about and it's like I'd such
respect for surreal we never see that on
Cartoon Network never well I don't watch
that much Cartoon Network so I'm just
going by the show in general I do
because I'm a grown man with no life and
I said no I did it just wasn't there
talking to me or I just was just I got
shot it just came off as like ok here's
a Cartoon Network show I would never
want to watch it noise what is one of
the things where if he may wanna show
itself is better but again like cuz I've
seen things like amazing world of
gumball I really like that show and
there's other shows on Cartoon Network
I've seen I've liked that have been
spiked more surreal and of course
there's Adventure Time health is this
this gets kind of surreal in certain
moments um well this seems like there is
just assuming there's like no story no
idea some characters a location and like
that's it it seems like they can do
whatever they want or you do my shows
they have traverses one is to entertain
barely did that for me there were a few
good moments the other is okay then your
cross-promoting
and if that was the case I just have no
desire to look at this show after Xena's
episode well and yeah you do bring up a
very subtle point there cuz like I say
with me watching it I'm like you know
like I said I appreciate one really
surreal silly humor can not only get a
lap but a big laugh out of me and like
said there's about five solid times in
this episode work I left pretty hard I
was like that that's really really funny
and for reasons I can't even fully
explain it's just so silly and so
straight watch Phineas and Ferb over on
Disney and that's got a fucking secret
agent platypus that's weird like I just
I don't know it sounds like a swan it's
interesting seeing a show that clearly
has a plot and a lot of continuity and
stuff interact with a show that I'm
assuming has none except for like maybe
like say characters at location that's
it uh and I can't I don't know if it
worked it was more okay from when it
started off
and my initial thought it was more
interesting had more laughs I thought it
was going to but can I say yes I want to
watch that uncle grandpa show probably
not because it would just annoy me too
much um but like I said you're still we
could take my reaction cross out the tea
I'm not and also cross out the probably
well played oh but no anything back it's
kind of like scary films like there's so
few things that can scare us so even if
I see a film that like bad but has like
five legit good scary scenes I'm gonna
be like okay well done like that
difficult to do for me um so I can't
hate it I can't say like you know oh god
this who thought this this was terrible
this is an awful show these are awful
ideas I never watching the crossover
again or anything like that
Oh awful as I said I loved the tiger I
kind of liked everything going on around
uncle grandpa not uncle grandpa himself
he honestly was kind of giving me the
fucking creeps yeah it's it's an
annoying voice at the wages of shit out
of his crotch then I'm sure it's like a
fanny pack but it's a fanny pack
baptized right it's very close to his
crotch it's also tooth his little vagina
dentata edge yeah um mice this kind of
shit would make the Japanese go like
woah I'm for those few moments I'm glad
I saw it cuz I like it when especially
you know being comedian stuff I like
when I see a kind of comedy where I
could say that's really frigging clever
like that really really smart uh and
silly
it's like smart and dumb at the same
time what's their honesty recommending
the generally boring stand-up routine
for the for funny jokes they were good
enough and I'm not saying I recommend it
I'm saying that cuz it someone I can see
someone totally liking that uncle
grandpa show if it's like that I can see
I'm fine in and if they like it in terms
of recommendation it depends on what
you're looking for if you're looking for
really
good surreal humor I would say there's
maybe about five jokes that are kind of
worth it and kind of like okay like it's
worth sitting through whatever 11 minute
so if you like to show 5 Jeff if you
like the show fine but that's not our
job our job is a did we enjoy it and
basically that's what you're saying is
you liked the stand-up routine for about
5 jokes out of a whole set yes and I
appreciate it
I appreciate the know I appreciate the
effort that it goes as far and crazy as
it does cuz I do know there is a risk to
it and if a lot of shows do it on
Cartoon Network I imagine that would
become annoying but again having seen
other things and having seen anime I
just this felt kind of cheap to me like
a lot of it was cheap too I mean I'm
like this lot as Mike I've seen utter
surreal shows and better use of
animation and but like you know and I'm
not that I'm not harping on the show's
animation in general I think the
animation general is great but if you're
just like oh this is gonna be the most
surreal thing I'm like no it's the South
Park Tiger was amusing that really is
about what did it for me um no I'm not
gonna say it's the most surreal thing
ever anything like that but it was it
had enough different kinds of strange
jokes that just that made me laugh
enough I said okay that's you know like
I'm glad I saw it for those five can I
say the whole thing is good
that's not really for me but like I said
I like those those five four or five
moments I to me still nothing was really
as funny as just like that stupid Sonic
the Hedgehog afternoon show worried
points and says hey I'm over there it
was about the same quality for me so I
yeah if you like Uncle grandpa
knock yourself out I mean that's all
we're here is to say what we like and
I'm just gonna say yeah not a fan I can
say I don't really have my last one
unless this is a complete shitty
representation of what uncle grandpa's
about I mean I don't know maybe like in
doing the crossover neither side got it
right
I have no idea but if this is what it is
and y'all have fun enjoy I don't know if
I could do just that voice alone I don't
know I literally I once stabbed myself
in here then that voice just oh yeah
which again I get it he's supposed to be
annoying it's almost like you know it
seems like it'd almost be kinda like a
troll show or something like that where
it's like you know we're just doing
everything are we fucking crazy isn't
this annoying isn't this annoying any
Internet's more fun so um yeah there it
is I think you can general idea um that
was our episode or that was our review
of an episode that is entirely not canon
um take it quickly we could have just
not reviewed it that's true but you know
everyone be like what you think about
what to think of it so and it's on
Amazon so and the fans of this episode
will be complaining about it anyway now
so if there are fans but iYou know that
is creating a reception I am curious cuz
like yeah some like particularly after
like Avatar and and Corrin some of the
other view logs we've done it always
amazes me the things that we sometimes
hate and be like oh are you just dumping
a can of worms on work or the mimic or
the things that when I hate ya were the
things that we like could be like oh
yeah fucking out of your mind vessels so
in this show so far I've been amazed
words is like some of the things we hate
there are a number of people just like
oh god yeah no nobody likes any oh yeah
oh this will be one of them like I don't
know maybe like oh god I hate that
episode to her baby would just walk into
horny Venice even the garlic even the
garnet fusion episode a lot of people
are saying like yeah I get that about
the height yeah I totally understand
something okay some people like here's
the funny thing that one some like I did
get some replies like you completely
missed the boat
I bet nothing to do with the whole gay
thing it's the fact that she's a fusion
you think that was amazing I'm like I
guess I mean she had three eyes so I
didn't necessarily see it coming in the
sense it but what it was a real of like
no it's cool that she was a fusion the
whole time that's cool
but it was cool
but yeah I was like some people just
like that was about the gay thing at all
we've talked about that it's veggies a
fusion like okay I you know what I just
I just want to enjoy the show just let's
enjoy the show make big call Ringling
Brothers
let us ruin it for you that's our job
any critics chairs so that's about it
well see you to ruin the next episode
later yeah